bonjour à vous jean marc sylvestre merci
d'être avec nous ce matin alors pourquoi
cette chute brutale de l'or noir aux
états unis c'est non seulement brutal
mais cet historique plus d'un siècle et
demi qu'on n'avait pas vu une telle
situation
le pétrole est descendu en dessous de
zéro c'est à dire qu'il fallait payer
des acheteurs pour qu'il puisse prendre
la gué de la cargaison alors la première
raison c'est une raison un peu technique
c'est que on est hier soir est arrivé à
terme des contrats de vente livraison ou
le mois de mai et ses contrats de vente
n'ont pas trouvé d'acquéreur ce qui fait
que les prix se sont se sont effondrés
et tout d'un coup mais tout ça est dans
un contexte dans un contexte de
surabondance du pétrole il y a eu depuis
à peu près six ou sept modes de
surabondance pour pour deux raisons la
première c'est que il n'y a pratiquement
plus de consommation ou très peu de
consommation d'énergie depuis deux ou
trois mois compte tenu du confinement de
la moitié de la planète
donc les gros pays consommateurs c'est
vrai se sont mis à l'arrêt mais il ya un
autre phénomène un contexte politique
j'allais dire géopolitique qui a fait
que nous sommes dans une situation de
surabondance de pétrole les pays de
l'opep ne se sont pas mis d'accord sur
une réduction de leurs oeufs de leur
production et vous avez eu pendant
quelques six mois à la une tendance à
l'augmentation des productions pour un
peu gêné les états unis on a eu des
accords entre l'arabie saoudite et la
russie notamment pour ne pas gêner tôt
pour ne pas baisser le niveau de
production ce qui fait qu on a une
surabondance de pétrole c'était une
action politique alors cet acte
politique elle demeure aujourd'hui alors
je sais qu'il ya eu un accord la semaine
dernière entre l'arabie saoudite et la
russie pour essayer de réduire la
production de pétrole
on a réduit de 10% ça n'a pas évident ça
ne suffira évidemment pas à rétablir
l'équilibré alors c'est à la fois une
bonne nouvelle parce que ça permettrait
de financer un rebond de l'économie une
énergie pas cher mais c'est aussi une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour toute une
industrie qui vit lui se demande ce
pétrole il faut pas rêver
jean marc sylvestre les prix à la pompe
il ne change pas un alors les prix à la
pompe ne change pas ils vont quand même
baissé un peu si on appliquait à la
pompe le prix qui s'est fait sur le
marché hier on paierait le litre
l'essence moins d'un centime aujourd'hui
mais il ne changera pas pour une raison
très simple c'est que entre la pompe et
le pays et le pays producteurs bien vous
avez un stade intermédiaire des
entreprises de transformation du
transport il faut bien qu'il faut bien
payer
et puis vous avez surtout énormément de
taxes parce que le pétrole notamment
dans les pays européens est un véhicule
de taxe très important puisque plus de
presque 40 à 50% du prix du pétrole du
de naissance que vous payez à la pompe
est bien va alimenter les caisses de
l'état que peuvent faire lopatin d'une
part et puis donald trump aussi alors
l'opep peut pas faire grand chose parce
que le peuple n'est pas forcément très
unie sur une position commune
les gros producteurs de pétrole pourrait
éventuellement faire des choses je pense
à la règle ça vous dit
je pense à la russie mais là la tendance
de la de l'arabie saoudite et de la
russie c'est plutôt de gêner donald
trump parce qu'ils savent très bien que
cette situation
le gène c'est un affaiblissement quelque
part de l'amérique puisque vous me
souvenais que ton halte roma avait
relancé notamment la production de gaz
de schiste pour pouvoir la conquérir
restaurer l'indépendance pétrolière il a
aujourd'hui cette indépendance mais il
déborde de pétrole il ne sait même plus
où le mettre son activité de production
et est trop faible donc les pays de
pétroliers sont à peu près au piège
parce que leurs recettes pétrolières qui
constitue l'essentiel de leurs revenus
finalement reubess alors l'arabie
saoudite a sans doute les moyens de
tenir mais vous avez d'autres pays qui
sont producteurs de betteraves qui ont
besoin des ventes de pétrole et de gaz
c'est le cas par exemple de de la russie
donc il pourrait y avoir une
manifestation internationale qui ou à
une prix
deux décisions internationales qui
pourrait faire changer la donne mais la
vraie la laverai la vraie chine havrais
le vrai événement qu'on attend
évidemment le déconfinement et la
reprise
la rebelle remise en marche des machines
économique parce que c'est le seul moyen
si vous voulez de rétablir les
équilibres rapidement puisque vous
parlez du déconfinement comment va
évoluer justement vont évoluer ses cours
de pétrole et bien théoriquement des
cours de pétrole ne bougeront pas
beaucoup dans l'est dans le mois ou dans
les deux mois qui viennent
parce que vous avez cette conjoncture
internationale qui n'est pas favorable à
la hausse
et puis vous avez les procédures de
déconfinement qui vont quand même être
assez longue à mettre en place mais
théoriquement on devrait revenir à des
cours de pétrole qui serait beaucoup
plus proche de ce que nous avions
auparavant que maintenant on ne peut pas
en être autrement
bon alors je sais que les mouvements
écologistes
ils sont assez puissante dans le monde
vont profiter de cette de cette occasion
pour réclamer une baisse drastique des
consommations mais la conjoncture ne s'y
prête pas on est dans un autre univers
aujourd'hui qui l'univers de restaurer
des capacités de production des trouver
des capacités d'emploi est le seul moyen
de retrouver les quarts et cette
production est de retour et d'emploi
c'est de faire redémarrer les usines
toxiques de leurs pairs consommer de
l'énergie
merci beaucoup jean marc seiwert rage
analystes éditorialiste économique sur
rt france merci à vous